SPEAKER_00: Hi Jennifer, thanks for coming in. I understand you want to reassess your risk tolerance after the recent market volatility?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I've been losing sleep watching my portfolio swing up and down twenty thousand in a day.
SPEAKER_00: That's completely understandable. The VIX has been above thirty for months now. What's your current allocation?
SPEAKER_01: Eighty percent stocks, twenty percent bonds. I'm forty-two, so I thought that was appropriate.
SPEAKER_00: The traditional rule of thumb would suggest that, yes. But... well, rules of thumb don't really account for your personal psychology.
SPEAKER_01: What do you mean?
SPEAKER_00: Well, if market swings are keeping you awake at night, you might be taking more risk than you can emotionally handle.
SPEAKER_01: But won't I miss out on returns if I get too conservative?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe, but what good are theoretical returns if you panic and sell at the bottom? I mean, that happened to a lot of people in March 2020.
SPEAKER_01: I came close to selling everything then.
SPEAKER_00: See? And if you had, you'd have missed the sixty percent rebound. It's better to have an allocation you can actually stick with.
SPEAKER_01: So how do we figure out what that is?
SPEAKER_00: Let's start with the numbers. What's your total portfolio value, and how much can you afford to lose without panicking?
SPEAKER_01: It's at about four hundred thousand right now. Um...
SPEAKER_00: Take your time. Think about dollar amounts, not percentages. If you woke up and your account was down fifty thousand...
SPEAKER_01: Fifty thousand? I'd probably throw up.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, what about twenty-five thousand? That's about, uh, six percent of your portfolio.
SPEAKER_01: That would be nerve-wracking, but I could probably handle it.
SPEAKER_00: Good. So if we can design a portfolio that rarely drops more than six percent in a month, you'd sleep better?
SPEAKER_01: Definitely. Is that realistic?
SPEAKER_00: With your current allocation? Probably not. The S&P dropped twelve percent in September '22 alone.
SPEAKER_01: Right, and I had sleepless nights that whole month.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. But if we reduced your stock allocation to say, sixty percent, the swings would be smaller.
SPEAKER_01: How much smaller?
SPEAKER_00: Historically, a sixty-forty portfolio has about twenty percent less volatility than an eighty-twenty.
SPEAKER_01: But also lower returns?
SPEAKER_00: Over the long term, yes. Maybe eight percent annual returns versus... well, nine-point-five percent.
SPEAKER_01: That's a meaningful difference over twenty years.
SPEAKER_00: It is. But remember, that assumes you stay invested. If volatility causes you to sell and buy at the wrong times...
SPEAKER_01: I could end up with even lower returns.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Studies show the average investor underperforms the market by two to three percent annually due to poor timing.
SPEAKER_01: So staying invested is more important than the perfect allocation?
SPEAKER_00: Bingo. A good portfolio you can stick with beats a perfect portfolio you abandon.
SPEAKER_01: That makes sense. What about the bond portion?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. Bond funds have been brutal this year with interest rates rising. The aggregate bond index is down, what, ten percent?
SPEAKER_01: I thought bonds were supposed to be safe!
SPEAKER_00: They are if you hold individual bonds to maturity. But bond funds have interest rate risk.
SPEAKER_01: So should I avoid bond funds?
SPEAKER_00: Not necessarily. They provide diversification and income. But maybe shorter duration funds would be less volatile.
SPEAKER_01: What's duration mean again?
SPEAKER_00: Roughly how sensitive a bond is to interest rate changes. Longer duration equals more price volatility.
SPEAKER_01: So short-term bond funds are less risky?
SPEAKER_00: From a price volatility standpoint, yes. Though they typically yield less than longer-term bonds.
SPEAKER_01: Everything's a trade-off.
SPEAKER_00: Welcome to investing. Risk and return are joined at the hip. There are no free lunches.
SPEAKER_01: What about alternatives? Like gold or commodities?
SPEAKER_00: They can provide diversification, but they're often more volatile than stocks. Gold dropped thirty percent in 2013.
SPEAKER_01: That doesn't sound very safe.
SPEAKER_00: It's not. Gold might hedge against inflation, but it's not a volatility reducer.
SPEAKER_01: What about real estate?
SPEAKER_00: REITs can be good diversifiers, but they're correlated with stocks more than people think. Especially during crises.
SPEAKER_01: They dropped with everything else in March twenty twenty?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Down thirty percent in a month. Correlations go to one when you need diversification most.
SPEAKER_01: So what actually provides true diversification?
SPEAKER_00: Honestly? High-quality bonds, despite their recent performance. And maybe some international exposure.
SPEAKER_01: International stocks have been dogs for years.
SPEAKER_00: They have, but that might be opportunity. European and emerging market valuations are much cheaper than the US.
SPEAKER_01: How much cheaper?
SPEAKER_00: Europe's trading at about thirteen times earnings versus twenty-four for the S&P. Emerging markets at twelve times.
SPEAKER_01: So they're on sale?
SPEAKER_00: Potentially. Value stocks have historically outperformed over long periods, but it can take years to play out.
SPEAKER_01: And I need to be able to stomach the volatility.
SPEAKER_00: Right. International stocks can be even more volatile than US stocks, especially emerging markets.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe a small allocation then?
SPEAKER_00: That's sensible. Maybe ten to fifteen percent of your stock allocation. Test the waters.
SPEAKER_01: What about sector concentration?
SPEAKER_00: Good point. Tech is thirty percent of the S&P 500 now. That's a lot of concentration risk.
SPEAKER_01: Should I avoid tech stocks?
SPEAKER_00: Not avoid, but maybe not overweight them. Total stock market funds give you natural diversification.
SPEAKER_01: What about individual stocks?
SPEAKER_00: For someone concerned about volatility, I'd stick with diversified funds. Individual stocks are much riskier.
SPEAKER_01: Even blue chips?
SPEAKER_00: Remember Enron? WorldCom? They were blue chips until they weren't. Company-specific risk is real.
SPEAKER_01: Point taken.
SPEAKER_00: Now, let's talk about your time horizon. When do you need this money?
SPEAKER_01: Retirement, so about twenty-three years.
SPEAKER_00: That's a long time horizon. You can ride out several market cycles. But if you're losing sleep now...
SPEAKER_01: The stress isn't worth it.
SPEAKER_00: Agreed. What good is wealth if the process of building it makes you miserable?
SPEAKER_01: So you're okay with me being more conservative?
SPEAKER_00: If it means you stay invested and don't make emotional decisions, absolutely.
SPEAKER_01: What allocation would you suggest?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe sixty-five percent stocks, thirty-five percent bonds? Still growth-oriented but, uh, more stable.
SPEAKER_01: And within the stock portion?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe eighty percent US total market, fifteen percent international developed, five percent emerging markets.
SPEAKER_01: That sounds reasonable.
SPEAKER_00: For bonds, maybe seventy percent intermediate-term, thirty percent short-term for stability.
SPEAKER_01: How do we transition to this allocation?
SPEAKER_00: Gradually. Maybe sell five percent of your stock funds each month and buy bonds. Dollar-cost averaging in reverse.
SPEAKER_01: So I don't try to time the market?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. You'll sell some at high prices, some at low prices. It averages out.
SPEAKER_01: That takes the emotion out of it.
SPEAKER_00: Which is the goal. Successful investing is mostly about controlling your emotions.
SPEAKER_01: What about rebalancing going forward?
SPEAKER_00: I'd suggest quarterly. More frequent than that and you might over-trade. Less frequent and you drift too far from target.
SPEAKER_01: Should I rebalance by calendar or by thresholds?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. I prefer threshold-based. If any asset class moves more than five percentage points from target, rebalance.
SPEAKER_01: So it's market-driven rather than time-driven?
SPEAKER_00: Right. You naturally sell high and buy low. It's a form of contrarian investing.
SPEAKER_01: I like that philosophy.
SPEAKER_00: It works, but it feels uncomfortable. You'll be buying bonds when everyone says they're dead.
SPEAKER_01: And selling stocks when everyone's optimistic?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Warren Buffett says be greedy when others are fearful, fearful when others are greedy.
SPEAKER_01: Easier said than done.
SPEAKER_00: True. That's why having a systematic approach helps. Takes some of the emotion out of it.
SPEAKER_01: What about during major market crashes?
SPEAKER_00: Those are the hardest times, but also the most important to stick to your plan.
SPEAKER_01: Even if everyone's predicting the end of the world?
SPEAKER_00: Especially then. Markets recover eventually. They always have. Though it can take years.
SPEAKER_01: How long was the longest recovery?
SPEAKER_00: Depends how you measure it. From the 2000 peak, it took thirteen years to break even in real terms.
SPEAKER_01: Thirteen years? That's a long time.
SPEAKER_00: It is. But remember, you'd have been collecting dividends that whole time. Plus making new contributions.
SPEAKER_01: Dollar-cost averaging during the decline?
SPEAKER_00: Right. People who kept investing during the lost decade actually did quite well.
SPEAKER_01: Because they were buying at low prices?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Same concept as rebalancing. Mechanical investing beats emotional investing.
SPEAKER_01: I'm starting to see the pattern.
SPEAKER_00: Good. The key is finding an approach you can stick with through good times and bad.
SPEAKER_01: This conversation has been really helpful.
SPEAKER_00: I'm glad. Sometimes people think being conservative means you're not serious about building wealth.
SPEAKER_01: But if it keeps me invested, it's actually better?
SPEAKER_00: Potentially, yes. Consistent mediocre returns beat erratic great returns you can't stick with.
SPEAKER_01: That's counterintuitive but makes sense.
SPEAKER_00: Most of successful investing is counterintuitive. The obvious moves are usually wrong.
SPEAKER_01: Like buying when everyone's selling?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Or maintaining your allocation when everything seems to be going to hell.
SPEAKER_01: I'll try to remember that during the next crash.
SPEAKER_00: Write it down. Put a note in your investment account. "Stay the course - historical perspective matters."
SPEAKER_01: Good idea. Should we start the rebalancing next week?
SPEAKER_00: If you're comfortable with the plan, sure. Remember, it might take three or four months to complete.
SPEAKER_01: And my returns might lag in a bull market?
SPEAKER_00: Possibly. But you'll also lose less in bear markets. It's about total risk-adjusted returns.
SPEAKER_01: And sleeping better at night.
SPEAKER_00: Don't underestimate that. Peace of mind has value that doesn't show up in performance charts.
SPEAKER_01: You're absolutely right.
SPEAKER_00: Alright, let's schedule a follow-up in a few months to see how you're feeling with the new allocation.
SPEAKER_01: Perfect. Thank you for talking me through all this.
SPEAKER_00: You're welcome. Remember, the best investment strategy is one you can actually execute.
SPEAKER_01: I'll keep that in mind. Thanks again.
SPEAKER_00: Anytime. Here's to better sleep and steady returns.